Guten Abend.
Ich heiße Hamidin. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistent, als Tätisch.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie da voran verstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Gut. Zuerst stelle ich ein paar Argumentenfrage.
Und dann kommen wir zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden.
Ist es in Ordnung?
Ja.
Gut. Sehr gut. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Miriam Halhuber.
Miriam Halhuber.
Halhuber. Ja.
Miriam, Frau, Frauinname, ja?
Ja.
Okay. Frau Halhuber, wie alt sind Sie?
48.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 10. Dezember 1974.
Gut. Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,70 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie bitte?
65 kg.
Okay, Frau Halhuber, was fult Sie zu uns?
Ja, ich habe so seit ziemlich genau einem Tag, habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Die werden auch stärker.
Und mir geht es einfach nicht gut.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Ja, die sind so im Unterhalb der Rippen, mehr auf der rechten Seite.
Rüster Seite.
Ja, unten die Rippen, ja?
Unterhalb der Rippen, ja.
Sie haben gesagt seit gestern.
Ja, ziemlich genau jetzt so 24 Stunden, ja.
Ja, okay. Und da sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Also, die begannen langsam.
Aber dann wurden sie relativ schnell auch stark.
Haben die Schmerzen aus Strahlung irgendwo hin?
Ja, es zieht so ein bisschen hier hoch in die rechte Schulter.
Und gibt es etwas, die Schmerzen vermindert oder verstellt?
Ja, ich habe gestern, dann noch in der Nacht habe ich noch eine Wärmflasche auf den Bauch gelegt.
Aber das war nicht so gut. Das wurde eher schlecht ab mit der Wärmflasche.
Wärmflasche?
Wärmflasche, also ein Beutel, wo heißes Wasser rein kommt.
Ja, okay.
Da habe ich mir auf den Bauch gelegt.
Manchmal tut das gut, aber gestern war das nicht gut.
Da waren die Schmerzen dann sehr gut.
Okay, haben Sie gestern auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt gegessen?
Ja, ich war gestern auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt.
Und da habe ich eine Brackwurst gegessen mit Pommes frites.
Das kann sein, das wird vielleicht ja, aber sonst weiß ich nicht,
kann ich mich sonst nicht erinnern.
Haben Sie etwas Eingenommen?
Schmeckenmedikamente?
Nein.
Schmerzmittel?
Nein, kein Schmerzmittel.
Hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden irgendwann?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Erst einmal.
Könnten Sie bitte mir beschreiben, wie sind die Schmerzen?
Schmeckenmedikamente?
Meistens ist das so ein Dumferstaats.
Aber manchmal kommt es zu einer Welle,
dass es dann auch so stark wird.
Aber meistens ist der Schmerz dumpf.
Dumf und ein bisschen wellig.
Frau Haluba, auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leichte Schmerzen und 10 sehr stärke Schmerzen.
Wo sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Ich würde sagen bei 7.
Frau Haluba, haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Ich meine zum Beispiel Obelkeit, Erbrechen.
Ich habe einmal erbrochen vor 2 Stunden.
Ich habe aber auch zuletzt überhaupt nichts mehr gegessen,
weil ich keinen Appetit habe.
Mir ist etwas übel.
Ich habe Schüttelfrost.
Einmal Erbrechen?
Einmal habe ich bisher erbrochen.
Und haben Sie sich feberig?
Ja, ich habe Schüttelfrost.
Ich habe auch vorhin einmal Temperatur gemessen im Mund.
38,5.
Ja.
Und ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, nicht.
Insgesamt bin ich müde.
Ich habe die letzte Nacht nicht gut geschlafen.
Ich bin ziemlich erschöpft.
Schlafst du nur wegen dieser aktuellen Beschwerden?
Normalerweise schlafe ich gut.
Ich habe meine Gewicht in den letzten 3 Jahren ganz konstant.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Atmen oder Herzrasen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nicht Probleme mit Wasser.
Wasser lassen ist in Ordnung.
Seit wann?
Seit den Geburtaren der Kinder.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit Wasser.
Haben Sie bestimmte Diagnose?
Ich nehme etwas Früchte, Trockenfrüchte oder Trinke.
Etwas Traubensaft.
Dann geht das etwas besser.
Ich darf nur keine Schokolade essen.
Schwarze Schokolade.
Ich habe eine Darmspegelung gemacht.
Vor 2 Jahren war alles in Ordnung.
Leiden Sie an krönchen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe oft Sort brennen.
Vor 2 Jahren hatte ich eine Magenspiegelung.
Der Arzt sagte, ich hätte eine Entzündung an der unteren Speiseröhre.
Ich habe die Medikamente genommen.
Ich nehme die Tablette nicht mehr jeden Tag, sondern 3-4 Mal in der Woche.
Wie viele Milligramm?
20.
Aber im Augenblick nur jeden zweiten Tag.
Ich habe die Tablette nicht mehr so stark.
Der Arzt hat gesagt, ich soll versuchen, jeden zweiten Tag zu nehmen.
Das geht gut.
Sonst, bevor ich krönchen kann.
Eine Schilddrösen-Tablette.
Ich nehme die Schilddröse mit einem Knoten.
Ich nehme die Öltirox.
50.
Ich nehme die Tablette morgens.
Sonst?
Nein.
Ich bin als Kind schon mal operiert worden am Blindarm.
Da war ich 10 Jahre alt.
Und die Operationen?
Nein, keine anderen Operationen.
Leider Sie ein etwas Allergie?
Nein, allerwie nicht.
Sind Sie vollständig geinst?
Ja, bin ich.
Alles Mögliche, was hier in Mitteleuropa notwendig ist.
Und auch bis hier drei Impfungen gegen Corona.
Der Arzt sagt, ich hätte die notwendigen Impfungen für Bier.
Ich mache etwas Nordic Walking.
Ich mache eine halbe Stunde, 3,4 Stunden.
Das mache ich.
Das meinen Sie regelmäßig?
Ja, ich mache regelmäßig.
Okay, Rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Ich mache ein bisschen Alkohol?
Ja, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Vielleicht am Wochenende.
Da trägt ich mal ein Glas Wein.
Aber das ist auch nicht viel.
Wenn am Wochenende insgesamt zwei Gläser Wein,
maximal drei Gläser Wein zusammen sind.
Nur am Wochenende.
Frau Haloba, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ja, sehr gut.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Schneiderin, Modeschneiderin.
Sehr gut.
Und sind Sie ferratet?
Ja.
Sie sind 18 Jahre alt.
Sie sind gesund.
Sehr gut.
Ich stelle jetzt ein paar Fragen über die Familienanwesend.
Leiden Ihre Eltern an freundliche Erkrankungen?
Wie heißt das Wort?
Familienanwesend?
Ich meine, Leiden ihre Eltern ab.
Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit, Schilddrose auch.
Der Fahrer ist 82 Jahre alt.
Der hat schon seit langen Jahren hohen Blutdruck.
Und hatte vor fünf Jahren einen Herzinfarkt.
Das hat er aber alles gut überstanden.
Und die Mutter, die ist 81 Jahre alt,
hat schon seit Jahren einen Herzinfarkt.
Und hat eine Atrose an der Hüfte und eine schwere Atrose am Knie.
Ich schulde mich wegen akustischer Probleme.
Ich habe nicht viel gehört.
Der Vater hatte einen Bluthochdruck.
Ja.
Vor fünf Jahren hatte der Vater einen Herzinfarkt.
Er hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Und der Mutter, der hat Schuckerkrankheit und eine Knieatrose.
Knieatrose und Hüftatrose.
Beides, Knie und Hüfte.
Hallo, Herr Hadim.
Sie stressen in der Arbeit oder in der Eltern-Alte.
Sie haben eine Schilddrose.
Nein, das ist die normale Belastung.
Aber ich rieche die Stress.
Die Arbeit macht mir Spaß.
Wir haben immer viel Arbeit.
Aber das ist in Ordnung.
Das ist gut. Ich habe keinen großen Stress.
Ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Sie haben eine Spiesenschaft.
Sie haben keine Schwester gemacht oder ink pay
worden.
Das ist so.
Die Ist sich vor zwei Jahren an der Galle operiert eighty
ก威.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Hab ich nicht.
Dann?
Ja, gut.
Okay.
Ich habe die wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie eine Frage an mich?
Oder möchten Sie etwas?
Was kann das sein?
Weshalb habe ich diese Bauchschmerzen und die Fieber?
Ja, weil hallo war.
Natürlich kann nicht bestimmte Diagnose stellen.
Klar, die ist der oder sagen aber ich habe Verdacht auf
Galblasen
Entzündung
oder
auch
Speicheldrose Entzündung,
aber die Diagnose zu bestätigen brauchen wir ein
paar אלgemeine
Untersuche und
Blutabnahmen
Abnahmen und andere operative Untersuchungen.
Kann ich jetzt noch etwas essen?
Ja, ich bitte Ihnen nicht zu essen, weil wir mussten Blutabnahme und es wäre besser ohne Essen.
Und vielleicht bekommen Sie noch mehr Erbruch.
So, bitte Ihnen ein bisschen zu essen und zu essen.
Ist gut.
Können wir so machen?
Abum, Kollegen, andere Fragen.
Eine Kollegin, eine Muslimin, fragt, ob Sie eine regelmäßige Menschersprache haben.
Was habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden?
Haben Sie regelmäßig eine Menschersprache?
Ja, habe ich noch.
Ich gehe auch über mich zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung und das war vor einem Vierteljahr, da war alles in Ordnung.
Hatten Sie seit Beginn der Bauchschmerzen einmal Stuhlgang oder gehen Wind ab?
Ja, ich hatte heute Morgen etwas Stuhlgang.
War aber nichts Besonderes.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe sonst immer so jeden zweiten Tag Stuhlgang, weil ich immer so etwas Verstopfung habe.
Aber ich habe schon vorhin auch gesagt bei dem.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Haut oder Augen in Leicester-Kagen gelblich geworden sind?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ich habe wassalassen, haben Sie irgendwelche Veränderungen verfallen?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Könnten Sie eke Vor- und Nachnamen bestärkieren?
Ja, ein Vorname Miriam, schreibt sich M-I-R-I-A-M. Miriam.
Und der Nachname Halhuber, schreibt sich H-A-L-L-H-U-B-E-R.
Halhuber.
Vielen Dank, Tasfas. Habt ihr Kollegen oder Kollegen ein anderer Fragen?
Sind Sie im Übersicht, guter Alphor?
Nein, Sie sind mehr unter der Rippe, unter rechts oder unter der Rippe so und gehen etwas in die Rechte Schulter.
Sind die Schmerzen immer da oder treten Sie nur hin und wieder auf?
Nein, Sie sind eigentlich immer da, nur manchmal kommt auch eine Welle, eine Verstärkung.
Aber nicht so oft, vielleicht so alle 10 Minuten, alle Viertelstunde.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Brustschmerzen?
Nein.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas Medikamente eingenommen?
Nein, bisher habe ich keine Medikamente dagegen eingenommen.
Ich nehme ganz selten irgendwelche Schmerzmittel, ganz ungern.
Aber deswegen komme ich jetzt ja hier ins Krankenhaus, weil es jetzt nicht besser wird, sondern eher schlechter.
Und deswegen möchte ich gerne untersucht werden.
Sehr gut gemacht.
Könnte wir anfangen mal mit, als das geschickt wird?
Ja, okay.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Abend.
Ich würde gerne die neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit für das?
Ja.
Ihre Name war Mirjam Haluba.
Sie ist 48 Jahre alt, geboren am 10. Dezember 1974.
Sie ist 1,70 m groß und wiegt 65 kg.
65?
Ja, 65.
Die Patienten hat bei uns heute Morgen wegen bestehender Dumm- und wellig Schmerzen vorgestellt.
Wo sind die Schmerzen?
Schmerzen in Hypo-frehnung oder in Rüste Oberbauch.
Die Patienten bewussten, dass die Schmerzen dauerhaft sind, aber mit welligartigen Charakten.
Die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten, im Laufe der Zeit sich verstärkt.
Sie klagten, dass die Schmerzen nach einem Fettessen gestern angenommen.
Nach einer fettigen Mahlzeit?
Ja, postgrande.
Strahlen die Schmerzen aus?
Ja, außerdem klagten die Patienten, dass die Schmerzen strahlen in den richtigen Schulter aus.
Die Schmerzintensität entspricht 7 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala.
Darüber.
Das Weitere klagten die Patienten über nausea und einmal vomitus.
Die Fikretative an der Mese ergab in Appetence wegen aktuellen Beschwerden.
Auch die Patienten über Fieber, die 38,5 war.
Wo ist das Fieber gemessen?
Sie haben gesagt, Mund ist.
Sie klagten auch über Schutterfuss.
Die Frage nach Spinde und nach Schweiß wurde vernein.
Die Frage nach Wasser lassen wurde vernein.
Die Patienten leidet ein chronischer Verstöpfung.
Obstipation.
Die chronologische Anamnese war unauffällig.
Bei der Patientin wurde ein Kolonoskopie durchgeführt.
Die unaufällig war.
Wann war diese Koloskopie?
Vor 2 Jahren.
Es gibt noch andere Erkrankungen bei der Patientin?
Ja, leider leidet die Patienten an.
Ein weiterer Verstöpfung.
Die Skopie zeigt eine Gestritis.
Sie hat gesagt, Entschuldung.
Sie nimmt 20 Milligramm.
Normalerweise 1 Tablette.
Aber zurzeit alle 2 Tage eine Tablette.
Daher nimmt sie als Substitut im Medikament.
Es ist eine Thüriodectomie, oder eine Stromectomie.
Sie hat einen Knoten.
Wahrscheinlich ist dort eine Partial-Nicht-Totelle für Tummi.
Und jetzt ist sie immer noch Hypothyroid oder ist sie jetzt Euteriode?
Hypothyroid, weil sie nimmt Substitut in den Edikament.
Und unter der Substitution ist sie jetzt Euteriode oder Hypothyroid noch?
Wissen Sie das?
Ich weiß, bei Hypothyroid.
Ja, okay, das war gut.
Gut, aber das wird immer kontrolliert bei der Patientin die Schilddrüse,
die Restschilddrüse und die Schilddrüsenfunktion.
Wissen Sie das?
Ich denke ja, weil Sie gut rekommensieren diese Aufhelligkeit in der Familienanahmnese.
Ja, ja.
Portirodo, bei Vater hat der Bett ist...
Nein, bei Vater hat...
Nein, bei Vater muss man keine Portirose.
Ja, aber andere Erkrankungen in der Familie, die erwähnenswert sind,
andere Vorerkrankungen in der Familie?
Bei Schwester gibt es eine Cholestektomie wegen Choleletiese.
Eine Cholestektomie, in welchem Alter, wissen Sie das, hat die Schwester die Cholestektomie gehabt?
Ja, vor zwei Jahren.
Und die Eltern sind die gesund oder haben die Erkrankungen?
Ja, der Vater leidet an arterielle Hepatonie und vor fünf Jahren
hat er einen Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Nein, der Vater ist nicht verstorben, er hatte vor fünf Jahren einen Myokartinfarkt.
Ah, nicht verstorben, ich habe den verstorben.
Die Mutter leidet an der Wettis Militus und Coxartrosa und Coanartrosa.
Die Schwester, vor zwei Jahren, bei der Schwester, vor zwei Jahren,
eine Cholestektomie wegen Choleletiese.
Bei der Schwester wurde vor zwei Jahren eine Cholestektomie durchgeführt.
Ja, der Epistetus ist vollständig.
Die Patienten ist dreimal gegen Covid-19, dreimal geïnft.
Die Frage nach allergien wurde für nein.
Die Patienten hat regelmäßig Sport.
Die Frage nach der Konsum wurde für nein.
Sie bringt gelegentlich Alkohol, ein bis zwei Glas Wein am Wochenende.
Die Roggenkonsum wurde für nein auch.
Vielen Dank. Können Sie mir Ihre Verdachtdiagnose nennen?
Ja, meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Choletistitis.
Akute Choletistitis.
Differenzialdiagnosen.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen in Betracht Bankriotitis, Hepatitis und Subfremd-Axis.
Ja, okay.
Wie wollen Sie jetzt vorgehen, diagnostisch?
Als erstes schrieb, kommt Korboschentursuchung und Blutabnahme.
Bei Blutabnahme Entschuldungparameter.
Okay.
Und die Patientin bekommt eine Infusionstherapie?
Ja, ja, ja.
Nahrung Carrens.
Okay.
Und ich denke, dann wird sie auch eine Oberbaustronographie bekommen.
Ja, nach dem, ja, allergiatiker Antibiotiker.
Und für die Diagnose, nach dem Blutabnahme,
wir durchführen.
Bei Durchfall, bei Ultraschall, wir bestimmen
Choletiasis, Cholestistitis oder auslischen diese Erkrankung.
Auch wir beurteilen die Leber, Bankrias und so weiter.
Also ich denke, wahrscheinlich ist es eine Cholestitis,
so ein bisschen spricht auch der ausstrahlende Schmerz in die rechte Schulter.
Ja, genau.
Bankriatitis kann auch eine Begleitpankratitis sein.
Ich glaube aber von der Schilderung der Beschwerden,
denke ich zunächst erstmal eine Cholestitis,
aber es ist eine problematische Region.
Gut.
Vielen Dank.
Ja.
Sie haben, denke ich, die Anamnese für mein Begriff gut systematisch
aufgebaut und auch abgefragt.
Bitte immer daran denken auch dann die medizinischen Fachbegriffe
zu übernehmen.
Beim Vater, haben Sie gesagt, der Vater hatte vor fünf Jahren einen
Herzinfarkt.
Das stimmt ja, aber dann sollten Sie dem Oberarzt sagen, der Vater
hatte einen Myokartinfarkt.
Das ist, denke ich, ganz wichtig.
Die Begriffe gonadros, Koksatrose haben Sie alles sehr gut
übernommen.
Das ist alles gut.
Und mit der Stromer und Stromer Nodosa und bei der Schwester
mit der Cholestistektomie, denke ich, das ist in Ordnung,
aber nur immer daran denken nochmal eine andere Sprache.
Und am Anfang haben Sie zu mir gesagt, als Patientin, ich
erhebe jetzt die Anamnese, dann habe ich erstmal gefragt,
was ist Anamnese?
Ich frage Sie jetzt nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte oder nach Ihrer
Krankheitsgeschichte.
Nur darauf ein bisschen achten und nicht zu lange Sätze
bilden.
Das ist immer so meine Taktik.
Je kürzer Sätze sind, desto weniger Fehler können
gemacht werden in der Grammatik oder in der Satzstellung.
Ja.